hello
rob here with mike mchardy what's up rob
we are playing gears of war ultimate
online
for the very first time yeah um just
about starting a game right now
different teams so we're enemies for now
unfortunately we are
opponents
but uh yeah you've been playing the game
yeah the campaign campaign um
you know they up-pressed everything to
1080 for the xbox one they redid cut
scenes they
they're adding content that has never
been on consoles before pc dlc that
they're bringing to xbox one now i have
not gotten that to that yet um i know
what
happens there's some kind of
stuff later on that i had like seen on
pc a while back but
so yeah it's kind of sweet trucking
through the campaign yeah campaign um
looks pretty good i saw i did like a
comparison of the cutscenes and they're
completely redone almost the level of
like you know like master chief
collection um halo 2 anniversary like
blur status like it looks um really
great
so we got war machine i i mean i played
this game a lot the first one back in
the day yeah um
loads of fun
yeah it feels you know having the xbox
one controller is nice and everything um
but just
you know definitely looks better it's 60
frames per second now right um
so yeah see how we do
yeah
see how it goes here this is one of
those games you guys have 4v3 i guess 43
for now
so this is blitz
okay
forget
what the specific oh okay so it's like
uh
zones kind of we have to capture
oh i remember this map for sure
nice
oh jammed my weapon
okay so we're in there
oh man it's been a really long time but
oh [ __ ] so so what is blitz i don't
remember so you capture these zones and
defend them
okay so it's just a
sweet
um
so they're going the other side [ __ ]
so you just have to stay in the zone to
get points i believe this is probably
bad a hot zone oh
geez he just hit him with us
oh damn was that you no no i don't know
it's just it's a it's a smoke out yeah
i'm just gonna keep going
so yeah
mastering the shotgun and the nasher and
not aiming is definitely still key just
as much as it used to be um
tried to melee there and he got the
upper hand on me really fast
so yeah now you guys have this reload oh
i'm gonna just
toss one of those in there
oh his head
is no longer there
so okay
yeah i have not played this game mode
i mean this is great
so we have to be in the circle to
right to rack up points
so what i'm doing is probably not
so yeah right now we are gaining points
because we have control of it oh it
changed damn i'm not paying attention oh
man
and this is also this is not execution
rules so you can kill them from far away
you don't have to actually curb stomp or
chainsaw or just be close to them i
guess in general
oh what am i doing i forgot this map
a lot i mean gridlock has burned into my
mind but
oh probably gonna need a round or two
i'm still on like
i'm still like clicking down sprint on
my left stick
yeah
yeah i've been playing black ops betas
kind of
oh they are all oh that's all of you
i can't see anyone i'm just shooting
there we go
oh i almost had the curb stomp
you ruined it for me
i got one guy
god you're so vulnerable yeah
so this is definitely a game mode where
i can see the shotguns just just being
all like shotgun battles up close
oh that's right blind fire
we work i mean we're still doing pretty
well
but [ __ ]
so there are power weapons like
scattered throughout the map right
there's a sniper rifle yeah i got the
boom shot someone's been using the torpo
a lot as well
yeah that thing is funny you get charged
up with the uh just
oh what am i doing i
gotta i really want to get a curb stomp
i'll get one right here
here we go
there we go
oh
yeah
yeah it is
oh [ __ ] oh damn it and then you got the
machine gun up here which i don't know
how useful this will be if i can see it
anybody that well that was my instinct
was like immediately after i get on it
you make yourself visible it's like oh
is that when you were talking about you
were vulnerable i felt like oh yeah
especially when the zone's up here so
this guy i can get actually you're
you're doing that good there huh there
we go okay so this i was a head shot
somehow with the machine gun
sorted to save that guy okay we're doing
pretty well with the machine gun but i'm
sure they'll come up here very soon and
that's a
saw josh you missed it
so it's gears war ii that introduced all
like the special weapon um
assassination
i'm getting
no one's come up here yet to stop me
from using this turret well because
they're getting points for being in the
zone oh never mind damn it i spoke way
too soon yeah
yeah the saw is the best feeling
it even even in campaign when you pull
it off like on one of the yeah or
whatever
i remember playing back in the day like
2v2 in my garage and you would oh that's
a torch you would want to refrain from
saul just because
it was also really great to like snipe
someone yeah as like he's being solid
well plus if you if you just shoot them
while they're trying to saw you that
interrupts it and then you're screwed
right oh there's someone else on the
machine gun now that sucks
i'm gonna try to get up there if
possible
so i kind of like that troika being up
there kind of creates this cool oh
someone just chainsaw the machine gunner
that's great does that noise is
hilarious yeah
just the fact that someone came up with
the idea to put a chainsaw bayonet on a
gun is oh
wrecked
all right i'm trying
and sticking a grenade on someone's gray
too
there we go oh yeah
but then it's also kind of fun to get
stuck and then dive at them as they yeah
yeah yeah you take them out
so we're playing at 210 it looks like
no
i blew it
oh you killed me i almost i almost saved
this dude oh
damn it
oh he just had a torpo too i might go
all right i want to get that torpo if i
was talking to this guy tell him to
stand here so i can go grab that
oh geez
someone's in the machine gun i can't
really move
we're so close
come on
there we go
oh he was right here too
uh maybe i shouldn't have been uh
taking my time with a curb stomp
i wasn't really paying attention so i
got we got a fair amount of kills but
that like four of those came from when i
was on a machine gun just kind of
spamming everyone oh really that worked
out yeah
i guess it kind of helped clean up the
zone so people could take it
that's an interesting game mode though
because outside of the circle you can
use whatever weapon but once you're in
there it's kind of just pull your nasher
out and
try to take it right or chainsaw if
you're lucky if you're communicating you
can you know say all right someone just
sacrificed their life to hold it down or
keep it something consistent yeah and
defend at least because i immediately
threw a grenade whenever i see three
guys in there yeah
so the
um
oh okay all these guys that's right
i was like carmine just because he had a
sick helmet
um so
oh man you can pick weapons so i have to
obviously unlock these
yeah
put these on
sweet skins
yeah
the red one these like glow red when
you're in the game oh really well yeah i
mean they're just really bright red so
it looked like it was more like a locust
kind of
so are we gonna play blitz again or
let's see i don't know
got a few other people leading this game
we're kind of just tagging along look
how badass these guys are
yeah
i've always played as barrett i don't
really like him but i always played as
him for whatever reason because all my
friends played as coal so i was like i
don't want to just poultry yeah what's
the sport he plays uh blitzball blitz
ball hence the game mode for the
cougars or the jaguars or something i
don't know yeah there's there's a team
anthony carmine and then benjamin and i
forget the third
they all just get sniped in the head and
well yeah he gets sniped in the head
right pretty early on yeah i remember
the cut scene for that it's
brutal yeah his gun jams and he's like
what the what's wrong with it and then
he has a much bigger problem right
afterward
so okay so up next we've got tyro
station which is a fun map that's when
the train comes through the middle but
you can also run out to get the torpo if
you're like brave
it's kind of like remember uh terminal
and halo 2 the guardians would kill i
would say killed by the guardians oh
totally yeah
oh that's right but other than that it's
like kind of a trench but two people
shooting from either side or two teams
shooting from either side rather
i do remember this yeah it's good
that's fun
it's cool there's like those dynamic map
events that happen but
still gives you room to just play
however you want yeah that's that that's
yeah it's exhilarating there's some kind
of like a horn or an indication right
that it's coming i think it's a like a
ding ding ding ding it's oh yeah it's
always funny to like you know have some
kind of showdown there and then that
just happens and it's like who can flee
first yeah
yeah that's great
try to get more power weapons i used the
sniper last match but i completely
missed oh sniper is so much fun
there are people that get really good at
the boom shot and know the exact arc and
right
i like the boom shot yeah
so boom shot
the bow
sniper
is there another one
is that right i mean later games they
introduce a bunch of weapons but right i
believe one just has those i mean you
you oh no hammer of dawn i was about to
say that yeah
it's on this map too oh wow that's
what's in the middle the torpos are on
each side okay so hammer dawn's in the
middle let's
try to get that and show that off
it's so tough though because it's got
that three second charge up from the
satellite yeah
oh there's no warning it just comes i
thought there was so then and then you
can you can obviously then
oh it's underneath
the um
the zone right now is underneath that
sucks
so we can't even use the hammer's under
there
oh [ __ ] so you guys got that way before
us
oh i was holding a or b can you get oh
you can get them stupid
he heard me coming with a chainsaw and
he schooled me oh that was great
he he did a one-up so have you do you
think you got the active reload time
down yet again
yeah i've been getting it more often
than not
um
that is such a cool thing they added
yeah like that was such a big deal it's
just such a mundane thing in most
shooters that reloading
yeah dang
oh i did get him oh god
i got some of the torpo at least there's
one power weapon
uh oh
oh
oh one of your teammates just exploded
here we go
curb stomp them
all right
aw damn i didn't even realize the zones
i'm thinking i'm gonna try to
oh [ __ ] is that you
is that you
yes no no oh you're relating i did an
active reload in the worst time i was
hoping i could get like a power shot
because you had the upper hand i thought
i screwed it up so we got this for a
little bit at least i still have a
torque two torque arrows left see if i
can pull one of these off
i hate that's the thing about the torque
with the charge once you have your
charger you gotta get rid of it
i've wasted a lot already
oh somebody threw us
no no one on that i didn't get anything
so
oh i threw a frag over there oh jeez
dang it's a smoke out
yeah that's the most unnerving thing
when smoke just starts pouring around
you you know someone's coming i like
this guy's coal outfit
oh so there are different skins yeah for
each of these guys you know oh i just
thought it was a guy sometimes it's hard
to recognize always the zone up top now
okay so this should be
interesting it's on the other side i'm
gonna try to get the torpo again
i like that i'm telling you like every
part of my plan
probably not helping my team effort
no i keep doing it i have no idea i was
not listening actually oh oh [ __ ]
oh my god i almost just dove in front of
that train like
butt head
nice
all right so
this is an interesting spot to have the
zone on the ramp because they can come
from
oh this smoke
do you not start with grenades i thought
you did smoke oh man i think you do
you pick up grenades up then huh
man that bleed out times there we go
there's a torque kill
no maybe not i think i'm just imagining
man
the guy had the coolest looking helmet
dang it damn
sort of close game i'm behind like 40.
and i'm probably slacking
here we go get down
that's what changed back yeah underneath
that worked out well for us we were all
spawning because you guys just killed
every single one of us
we were sort of close to it
i'm on your team
man
can i step my game off
yeah so
you know more people in
inside the circle the faster it goes it
looks here we go okay oh yeah i'm
not doing well at all
oh geez nope uh
i went in kind of expecting the chainsaw
and it didn't work
i need a hot power weapon so where are
these power weapons you got what's pull
uh what's turbo on either side i think
the hammer of dawn is right in the
center of the tracks i don't know if
there are any others there might be a
sniper rifle but i
i know for sure i've been using torpo i
got at least one kill with it
you're going down for sure
i wish you could use meat shields in
this game
that's right and you get pistol yeah
later on
or at least in gears war two you can i
mean
which
for anybody interested if
they missed the news if you do
get gears of war remastered for xbox one
and play it before new year's you have a
download code for free for um
all four other gears games one two three
two three
judgement and that cost of my life and
you get them for xbox one backwards
compatibility which is pretty cool so
you get like all five games that have
come out for it that's great four games
including the remastered oh
this guy just got ran over
yeah
wrong way
i love they didn't even bother making it
look like a realist i don't know how it
would look if you got run over by train
but instead they just made the body just
disintegrate oh man the mechanic
mechanics are so weird for me i gotta
freshen up oh
there goes my teammate
he made the train so oh the capture
position's in the middle that's
interesting oh wow
i'm gonna get another
so that
seems
troubling because
i don't want to go out there we are
really close right now but you're only
winning by five oh jeez
oh let the train oh we're about to get
ran over we're both that was you yeah
oh that sucks oh
you just you just die i guess yeah you
gotta go for it i wonder it i can't
remember if
it doesn't cycle to another spot unless
a certain amount of points are gathered
or if it just we could wait this out and
kind of just keep other people out of
there sure i'm gonna try to save this
guy oh my god
oh this is a close game
oh there's a chainsaw
no no my
watch okay so i see it just runs out of
point
i got a kill off at least
this train is taking a while here we go
it's a busy station should i get the
hammer yep i'm gonna get it oh no
i don't know this map
damn it
no people are sending me messages you
should turn notifications
this guy's good
dude this guy
is moving how is he not dead
this guy's in a football uniform and i
just chainsawed him
still close game
i just have blood all over my face
oh i was really close to that oh man
uh oh
sorry
all right all right one to one cool one
yeah
all right good i wasn't last i didn't i
had a bad start
both that same amount of cash you were
killing me that time
i downed a lot of people that i did not
kill mm-hmm
i guess some of these power weapons
cool so that's tyro station tairo
station
i think the one that most people are
familiar with is gridlock that was kind
of the
famous gears map it was like the
town-ish it's like a highway and then
those buildings in the center and the
sniper up in this overwatch kind of spot
yes it was on a highway you're right
yeah the sniper there was a sniper on
the left and then there's like the boom
shot in the arc yeah yeah so everybody
tries to go for the boom shot yeah
people are watching over it kind of just
screws things up
yeah that's right then you would always
you'd rush against each other over to
come back okay we're gonna get back into
this oh no never mind we're all still in
the same part um but you would rush the
sniper right and then you'd be like
one-on-one you could see the guy yeah
with his back against the wall and
you're both like go for it like he's
gonna like go for the sniper and throw a
grenade or whatever that smoke wagon
yeah quieter was that whiter tombstone i
think so i don't know that one i don't
know why my mind jumped from gears of
war to tombstone
um yeah i'm not sure if we're getting
showdown two more people in here or what
yeah
but anyway yeah so this came out in like
seven years ago
what year was that 2008 or seven i
believe it was either late seven or
early oh eight um
it was definitely late
in the fall
um
and then the coalition who worked on
this remaster is doing gears of war 4
which is their first like original
title so it's like rod ferguson who
helped work create the first game at uh
epic he's coming back to do
gears again so they showed the e3 demo
right what was it like a monster like a
flying monster on the roof or something
flying monster and then there's the last
one we had were these like dog-like
dudes with with multiple layers of teeth
and i think they had like tentacle
tongues you know the works yeah he's
playing through the campaign for this
it's definitely
more horror driven than two and three um
you know there's the berserker part
there's the krill where you have to stay
out of the light or the those birds that
will tear you apart that's right which
is pretty terrifying because sometimes
the lights will go out and you'll have
to just sprint to the next light before
they
right rip you apart
um yeah these are always fun i remember
playing with my brother with these uh
gears the first three at least uh it was
a really great co-op yeah these are
those games where you kind of want to
play co-op especially with two and horde
mode came out it was one of the first
horde modes which was great you could
play like for six hours and just be
getting to level 50. right
cool starting off here
was this on mansion i remember okay this
one's oh i do remember this one too it's
kind of cool i've it's been a while
since i've already got the main menu i
have a little
hiccup here
do you see it because i think so that
was blitz assuming we're gonna do a new
game mode now yeah that'd be great um
because yeah they are adding for
remaster they're adding team deathmatch
which was never in the first game it's
most the time with war zone execution
you have the it's one respawn or no
sorry no respawn it's just you would do
rounds and you wouldn't respawn you just
get killed and you try to survive
team deathmatch is when your team has a
pool of respawns i think it's
10
and
that just that's a pool for everyone so
if one guy dies like 10 times the team
won't have any respawns or if each guy
dies twice then it'll just be
elimination from there on out that uh
that lobby must change pretty quickly
yeah like after every match yeah not
playing with this dude no
just kind of it's it's a cool dynamic
because you'll be you'll be like okay
we're fine i could die a few times it's
not gonna affect it but then everybody
does that and you're at like two more
respawns like oh [ __ ] this is gonna suck
and then there's uh
boxes this new map that i
think was on the pc for a while it's
just the center of this one map and it's
really close quarters like just gnasher
shotguns just like four of these crates
that everybody's kind of dodging around
the whole time
cool
and that we you said that was just for
pc
or when the game came out on pcc um
boxes might be completely new um for pc
there's the campaign content that they
added oh excuse me later on
um and then team deathmatch i believe is
just completely new as well
um hey well could we switch teams i
think someone wants to
okay
that way is that what that is
it looks like you could possibly do it
nope
cool to play on the same team but too
late
oh wait here we go
i don't know nevermind
forget it so we got here what map is
this
process okay
oh this is yeah a lot of just catwalks
kind of reminds me of like
the scene when um joker falls into that
vat there's a lot of those huge vats of
acid and
or it might be the emulsion emulsion
yeah which turned locus into lambent
which they're like the third faction of
the campaign
they're like the flood of gears of war
that's right they're like zombie-like
yeah they explode and stuff mm-hmm yeah
i think this is more of a close quarters
map i really like them remember
that's the one with the um just like
tractor trailers everywhere it's like
this kind of gas station looking place
yeah i remember that yeah gridlock is
still my favorite yeah gridlock
uh i remember the most for sure okay
here we go all right so yes this is the
one i was thinking of
it's always tough when you have your
nasher just ready to go but then you
realize
they're not close enough yeah they've
already shot you 20 times
so there's a torpo
oh
oh he was waiting for me that was dumb
oh also
i'm not respawning
didn't realize
oh i saw a sniper here what was it oh
i just got kicked out of that very early
long shots go
someone's playing as anya
there's like the coalition skin right
there oh
first shot
one shot that's all that's all i did
that round um
one death is all i did that round
okay that's fine
yeah
so yeah just execution i probably should
have read that before we start okay
and also yeah execution you can't even
you have to be pretty close to him to
kill him
yeah this was definitely the mode
yeah
that was
high
intensity
oh man this is a
oh
that was that was me i think that was
you oh that's another
did you get three kills right away i
think i got three it was really good
did the old flank four or was that oh
there's a total total yeah got it
i'm at a healthy zero
see if we turn that around this round
first of four rounds all right
we have time to redeem ourselves slash
myself um
ah damn it
yeah i don't know these maps oh let me
get the sniper dude
i thought the other guy was going to
come around this
behind you so i was kind of just trying
to yeah
was so perfectly timed with that
explosion yeah wow
this is three guys and then blood
oh man that was really satisfying
to watch at least
okay so you guys want two to one you're
winning
move
i don't even i don't even want any other
gun out beside my shotgun
so there's that kill he's out
and i do not know these
parts
oh god no
damn it
i just got chainsawed you trying to
chase him
get out of here
oh i'm watching him
the guy shooting you right now
get closer
man i so i thought i had you were close
well i had the active reload i thought i
could
get a higher image
he went for a chainsaw see that
sacrificed himself not an execution you
shouldn't be doing that excuse execution
yeah curb sounds fast or just shoot them
from up close yeah
yeah honestly like
showmanship aside the shotgun's probably
the best way to execute someone really
quick and get out of there right
yeah let's see where they are
the machine gun is more of an assist
not seeing that if you know if you're if
you're far away just help out your
teammate or whatnot there's a lot of
cameras
all right we'll go back to playercam
is it a one-on-one
nope or yeah it is
let's see if we can do this right
yeah yeah
see how uh oh there we go
there it is oh man the sniper oh he's
got the sniper
so with an active reload on the sniper
you can actually you can down someone
right uh oh yeah you better switch
oh this is
you shooting at his feet
so he's doing like he's doing the
quickie i usually shoot from the hip
with the shotgun
oh really so i i'm the opposite i guess
it's probably better
okay so tied up
both need two more good lord
twitch guy so is that best of seven
first four yeah
there's bear just
cursing for no reason i took cover and
he said [ __ ] yeah
oh
you jerk nelly
you guys you and some other person
versus well never mind
oh man that sniper
it's fun how satisfying was that to not
only stop my torpo but just blow my face
up well it's funny is like i i was the
first on another guy and then i saw you
in the way back charging up i hated it
so much
you're mine because i could just be
imagining it wrong but i think i was
about to hit someone with it oh no it
looked like it that's why i like went
for you i was like all right you're
about to [ __ ] you're about to wreck
someone
did you kill someone else with a sniper
rifle that round
victim i i down someone or at least okay
[ __ ] yeah people are going for the pup
what i really like about the layout of
these rounds too is like switching
oh [ __ ]
oh my god
the spawn swap yeah like it just changes
the rounds up yeah
like i won't go for the sniper every
time
speaking of sniper oh man it's really
dark right here
i don't even know who i'm shooting at oh
man oh man
yeah our last person has a sniper rifle
team up with this guy oh he does oh my
god that was a really good shot
he's dead now but i think he's dead now
there he is
he's still alive let's get him
oh no
if he gets out of this dude
stop oh my god he's playing cat and
mouse around that pillar oh there we go
i want it
we both try to do at the same time
he had a really good shot someone was
roadie running like
two feet from him and he got a head shot
oh wow
you're crushing it this round
it's working out
what's what is the roadie i mean i know
what it is but like where's that come
from the like roadie
uh the name at least i have no idea
i think that's what it was just called
in the game i could be wrong
but yeah just obviously the camera
shakes so much you don't want to use it
too much yeah
sprinting in
cool
yeah that i like back in the day we had
i had the halo set up like permanently
in my garage and when this game came out
we did the 2v2 yeah i remember i had
these jerk friends
uh
who like bet they thought they were hot
shots and they bet me and my buddy
and we bet money on it we did like 25
each oh yeah and then they did they
double downed and we're like all right
let's do it and it was so intense
and they never paid they stormed out
you should just text him right now and
see yeah right remember that and he'd be
like nah nah nah nah uh okay so we can
switch teams let's try to yeah so would
i need to do that as well or i mean yeah
press y
you might switch to the first guy
there we go cool same team so you can
stop killing me now
or we can actually like
cooperatively yeah
do something all right here we go so
this is mansion this is one we were
talking about it's a good map this is a
great map because there's a few rooms
inside where it's just very close
quarters
i think you can go inside if i ever oh
yeah oh and there's something there's
like the yeah there's the um
kind of like the double stairway and
then there's uh i don't know what
probably sniper on top yep like a foyer
right i think it's a sniper it looks
like there's something right in the
lobby too yeah that's right and you can
go around the sides i like this map a
lot yeah
it's based on that part in the campaign
i think when you go to
marcus's dad's mansion like where marcus
grew up sure uh his dad was the one who
invented the hammer of dawn so he's kind
of like the oppenheimer i guess of gears
of war i don't know
i forget about all this stuff
crazy how much stuff i remember about
this game
yeah i i don't even know like i
definitely played one and loved it and
then i went to go inside i like came
back to three i think i played two and
then i
played three really late like i just
forgot about it oh i totally remember
this yeah
so
oh yeah this is only it
you guys want to go i think that's a
bolt-off pistol at the bottom on the
ground floor i'm going for it
oh [ __ ] okay i'm coming over there oh
come on i probably should have been here
do you have to hold that one it's
execution i can get you i can get you
got it you did it we gotta get out of
here though yeah yeah i can get you i
can get you
thank you all right let's get
out of here oh the couches are falling
apart come on i'll get you again back up
back up back up oh it's a grenade how
stupid did we look to the other team
just taking care of dying
oh man at the very least if you down
okay i'm gonna try to get this guy
oh damn it i am show yourself
do it i'm just gonna get him i'm gonna
oh my god he got back off
bleed out
thank you
yeah there we go nice this other guy's
down
two chainsaws
was that four did we also buy that nice
that was pretty great yeah that was good
dude it's sniper man occupied half that
round just me and you taking turns dying
yeah yeah i know i said this already but
if i so if i get the active reload
and i just got a body shot that's an
immediate down isn't it i think so i
mean or if they're enabled i think yeah
the different weapons have different
bonuses um i know with the full talk or
sorry the
with the torque bow it's just
it the active reload just makes it so
the aiming laser will just immediately
snap
when you have to charge it up come on
come on come on i keep doing this
be good i'll
he's right across there if you can get
the head shot if you could down him i'll
go finish him off or just get that show
yourself
nice shot all right if you can get that
other guy i i've beefed it all right
he's in this doorway if you can
oh if you can always down him i'll kill
him it's actually a little also they
might be going around you i don't see
anything yeah you know what i'm
and i keep forgetting they're not
shooting they've got to be on the other
side oh come up the stairway i think
no that's ours they're probably coming
around the other side
yeah look through that smoke
well i'm behind us in case they do that
because i've not seen them for a while
here we go left
do it
dare you
do it do it
that's what's crazy he can totally see
me
oh downstairs too on the left
um
you know that bar
oh
this guy's here
tricky
oh here he comes on the left
up the stairs
ah we're just on the left i'm sorry
oh [ __ ] yeah where is everyone
this is very just like unsettling
oh
oh he's the last person i didn't realize
we killed everyone else
because you she got the head shot
yeah i got one sweet
not a bad start
no they probably well they definitely
shouldn't have put this twitch guy on
our team if they wanted to
all right that guy's really good kind of
like going inside right away
although actually i don't know maybe
next round i'll kind of flank around the
outside i'm in love with the sniper
rifle that's all i want
give you some uh
i don't see anyone inside yeah they kind
of just gave us the top floor yeah they
realized that there's not there
um you know oh yep front door
yeah
that's the perfect spot oh oh our guys
are okay
i might just go
around by myself and see if i can pull
anything off oh boom shot dude get out
of here everyone get out of here this is
oh my god
oh my god it was over our heads oh you
saw the actual oh yeah yeah dude we were
all there you want to go outside
yeah definitely okay let me go this way
oh oh that's me no i keep like because i
was killing [ __ ] all day all right let's
get my nasher out
i've not seen anyone let's try to get
around them
i'm trampling each other
he just killed all four people oh man
that was really funny jeez
you would have
you would have had that
look at this team they've killed one of
us
yeah or downed oh that first one we kept
downing each other just go up around
outside if you want to get the sniper
rifle off yeah go for it change it up
try to get around them i'm gonna wait
back here oh no they're all out front
all right
three of them are at least yeah if you
can if you can come down and get a shot
from the side with the sniper dude
dude
i'm flanking him i'm just distracting
him for now we got another guy out here
got two oh he's about to die
let's go dude he's coming in the front
okay
hang tight one's done i'm gonna
do some major flankage someone's coming
at me with a shotgun
all right i got
got one guy
two of them are down oh he boom shotted
me
yeah he boom shot me i'm still uh
there's one left and he has a boom shot
though heads up
there we go yeah i got one kill before
he killed everyone else
but mainly twitch
good job though
man that guy is a reckon
i forgot what does ranking up get you in
the first gears of war anything is it
just cosmetics
or even that or it's just like a mem of
like a matter of
i definitely write i definitely think it
was um
characters
okay i'm pretty sure it took some time
to get certain characters but i'm not
positive to be honest yeah i don't i
don't know
i think it was just bragging rights fair
or at least maybe you could start off
with like the locust yeah um it's kind
of like a burst fire
i think i like that more
okay
so what else oh so you're just in
cosmetics
yeah
can you you can't change the shotgun at
all
i could yeah it was just to the red and
the default i do have there are other
ones i just
have not i think you might
so in the remastered you get the cog
tags unlock these um
comic books that kind of go back to e
day and before that when they were
designing the hammer of dawn but as far
as the cosmetic thing goes i think
like pretty much all of the dlc all the
um the like weapon skins from the first
game are included with the remastered
edition
i just don't think i've activated them
yet um
garden i do not remember gardening i
don't remember this at all
another execution
i can't hear one of these guys he's
probably chatting he's on the other team
he's probably a little pissed
you have time to switch teams
all right here we go okay garden
do i recognize this so i do like how
in the beginning i didn't know oh we
start off with a sniper
oh
tight whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
poison gas apparently did you all run in
there and die
i'm the only one get out yeah i'm the
only one left you have to like
deactivate oh my god look at hammer of
dawn boom shot okay so what do you do
yeah
oh
i am matt okay i'm not gonna do that
again no
oh
dude there was absolutely nothing you
could have done
i don't know if there's a switch to
deactivate that or what
i don't remember this map at all i don't
remember
okay
i love that you were so excited like
you're just christmas and then all of a
sudden i know i think poison gas
murdered you that was awful
i looked up at the uh the icons at the
top left and saw i was the last one and
yeah that was uh hands for a second that
was a bummer
so now it's just everyone in this one
i'm gonna throw a smoke just to do it oh
good
god boom shot
again yeah where are they finding that
just right in the center dude i think
you have to like
jump in jump out is it that i don't know
i mean they have to have their be nice
to be oh so we got the hammer it'd be
nice to play a private match and kind of
figure that out oh god guy down
someone's
kilroy
who's gonna make a move first
damn it
ah he got me
[ __ ] oh
the other guy's right near you too
oh they're all dear
man
look who's
alive you don't hear yeah you're on the
aiming oh my god
the aiming is
it also makes you pretty vulnerable see
that's one thing you get you start
learning is to move around using cover
and not oh yeah you're totally right
although he's not i will say he's
exceptionally good my god dude
okay nope
did you see the one cover switch where
you just
killed two people doing it what was that
didn't know we were playing with robots
didn't know we had an alien on our team
good lord all right i'm gonna try to get
this sniper oh man i'm
not gonna encourage that but well i know
you reach his own
you're so
[ __ ] that sucks that's stupid what do
we have to do
there's there might be a valve or
something
oh you hear that
i heard a power down and then they got
the sniper rifle yeah there must have
been something there's a power down
noise all right so they have the boom
shot and the sniper rifle which is yeah
but we have twitch so what what's the
matter he's the secret weapon
all right there's one oh oh god that's
dude he's like
he knows where we are oh so you know uh
behind you
you got some activity
you're getting
me yeah well i'm watching him
you guys are next to each other there's
there are some guys he was running away
from they were coming closing in
closing in on you
i'm just gonna stick in your hem
dude he was so close to dying in the
last round that was pretty amazing it
was just weird how he wasn't even doing
the dodge it was just
just going wall-to-wall which is crazy i
mean i've seen people do it before but
that's all new to me i it makes sense
though that's what i mean it's for
dodging and for just moving fast right
all right
can you us it's like he's skiing yeah
um
can you do what can you cycle through
the cameras and see if you can see where
i hope they don't see me
yep we see them all right we're right
behind with the boom oh oh
they don't even know it they don't even
know oh i want a chainsaw oh god it's
the hammer of dawn and the boom shot
sweet
so that means i can't really stick you
also if they have the boom shot and
hammer you probably want to separate
yeah good call i'm gonna get out of here
uh do you think they see me right now
turn this way just in case um
all right i got a nice little shot of
them
damn it damn it damn it
oh my god that thing is so terrifying
wow
yeah it's like a crisp oh jesus
come on get out of it
they're just hanging out next to each
other i can't get close to him because
all right i just
he he doesn't look like the hammer guy
doesn't know you're coming so he's okay
we're on either side of them twitch guys
mopping up
oh he's gone
just me and him yeah
i don't know where he is
let's try it anyway
it's the guy with the hammer though he
has i wonder if he picked up the boom
shot
there he is i don't know where he's i
can't tell i don't know his map
he's coming like central oh oh yeah i
see you so he's he's too you're right
yeah he's there he is okay
i mean if he's got that i'd have to
sneak up on him i imagine
there he is
i really want to end with a chainsaw but
i don't want to get locked into that
idea because that's when i do stupid
[ __ ] yeah i would
so what does he have actually on my
hammer he might have picked up the boom
shot oh he does have the hammer yeah so
does this guy oh
hammer duel all right let's see if this
works at all oh he's he's firing at he
sees you now
i've never done this before
he's come
around he's i don't know where i can't
it's hard to pinpoint
like camera oh he's coming up there
he's
he's running left yeah
should i just fake him like psychomount
just go up the shotgun i don't have my
shotgun i got rid of my oh i don't have
my shotgun
he knows it
just get out of there just get out
oh god
oh i was oh damn it
i never get rid of my shotgun why'd i do
that
yeah i've done that accent
i've never gotten in a hammer duel like
that before
that's cool
all right so where the hell is this
switch
i don't know um it's definitely look for
like a red valve that's what they look
like in campaign and it sounded like
that's what they turned
um i'd imagine it's on the other side of
this greenhouse right here
[ __ ] it
i haven't done anything i'm just going
to kill
you they're like
because they get they they keep turning
it off and
having no problem with it oh man
no how long can you do that for i
thought it was like a
it's uh it's like a meter that runs out
also i got the boom shot which is nice
damn it i missed
oh man that thing is
oh this guy down oh my god that guy
almost got me the sniper now i have a
sniper
now i have a mission is that our guy
oh man i'm not i just downed him again
oh i found the switch
now
there you are
all right yeah he yeah finished him off
i got the sniper right here there we go
cool i got one kill
i found that switch oh yeah um where
that
that middle area greenhouse if i mean
it's just
these like three switches it looks like
now it's yeah cause the boom shot was
just out in the open off to where we
were kind of hiding up those stairs last
time myself and twitch
yeah i'm gonna go for it again actually
if no one else gets it
yeah so i the kill i got with the boom
shirt he was aiming right at me the
sniper rifle and kind of got the last
second
oh you can just
well this is stupid why would you i'm
down if you can see me um hold on a
second
try to get over there
nope
man i'm paying it oh yeah god oh i
downed him
it's probably so stupid to go over and
try to kill him right now but
get at least one out of the way
you lost twitch
nice should i just shotgun him i took
way too much time with that oh so you
got two guys oh he was
wrong button
guess what else i got though he's coming
in
he's got some that guy's got something
chest sniper i think it's probably gonna
come on your right
oh nice
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh nice
dude here we go money
i don't think i i down someone with a
boom shot i didn't really do too much
else with it though
tight
nice work there we go i was really
worried the other guy was gonna stop
bleeding out and get up
so that's the whole thing with the with
the aid right you tap a you can get back
up um
later they took out the um where you can
crawl you remember you used to be able
to crawl when you were down um to try to
get the cover
but no yeah you just it used to be you
tap a to slow down the bleed out but in
execution specifically you get back up
after like 10 seconds or something maybe
a little shorter than that
behind you is that you that's you behind
you
man i saw come on i got you i'll get you
what now oh i almost said i'm so sorry
kill him for me if i'd known that was
you i would have warned you earlier but
i thought it was one of the other guys
well i keep trying to get a power weapon
oh he's got the boom shot these switches
are annoying
oh i turned it on the left he's coming
around to you
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
what the hell he killed himself
he got an assist for his own death did
you oh no it's my asses never mind
someone got twitch pretty early on
no he's a lasso oh oh we have two i
thought they had two
oh
that one
who's going to finish him he's shooting
me just tell him to kill him i think
i'll take a bloody victory over a clean
loss
nice i think that's the last match
that we have time i i'm not sure but i
think so
well i went out pretty lame one kill
damn that was good that was fun yeah
it's crazy how much like muscle memory
just comes right back
right
it's it's the timing of everything too
it's that's what's really fun is like
shaking out people with walls and such
like the cover system is
this is its own
deal which is fun
yeah
but yeah so i think that's is that it
i believe that's the end of that
yeah i think
okay probably done just back out then
you back out yeah
anyway anyways so that's remastered
multi or sorry gears war ultimate
edition
multiplayer remastered
first gears of war yeah uh good stuff
it's i mean if you've played gears of
war
what you see is what you get plus 1080
plus 60 frames per second some new
uh remastered maps and obviously a
couple of new maps or just one new map
a couple new maps new game mode team
deathmatch right
um
yeah new campaign missions and the if
you play before new year's you get all
four games as xbox one backwards
compatible
titles sweet awesome thanks mike yeah
thanks for playing rob see you guys
you